اعلنت شرطه العاصمه البريطانيه ان ضباطا
مسلحين اعتقلوا شخصا بعد حادثه اصطدامه
سياره بوابه مقر الحكومه في تن
داوننجان واشارت الشرطه الى انه لم يصب
احد في الحادثه
اضافه ان اعتقال الشخص تم بشبهه احداث
اضرار اجراميه وقياده السياره بشكل خطير
وانها بدات التحقيق في ملابسات الحادثه
اذكر ان تتمينج سيت والمقر الرئيسي لرئيسي
الوزراء البريطاني
وهو ايضا مقره وزير الخزانه جريمه هانتس
ومباني حكوميه اخرى تخضع هناك للحراسه
الامنيه المشدده من قبل ضباط مسلحين على
مدار الساعه
هذه صور مباشره
لتندام مقره رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه
وقد تعرض
الحاجز
الحديديه الذي يفصل المقر عن الشارع هناك
الى حادثه سير لا نعرف طبيعته ولكن
الشرطه تقول بانه قد توجه لسائق السياره
الذي اصطدم بالحاجز هناك فهنا اسرائيل
والقياده بطريقه
غير مسؤوله
ينضم الينا من لندن مراسله الجزيره اسد
الله الصاوي اسعد الله
هل هناك من تفاصيل جديده قيل بان التحقيق
بدا في الفور على الفور
فور اعتقال
السائق ما الذي يحدث
جمع كما ترى نحن الان امام مقر الحكومه
البريطانيه في رقم عشره السياره الفضيه
التي تقف امام البوابه بالضبط الان هي
السياره التي تم استخدامها في الاصطدام
بالبوابه سائق سياره يفترض انه شخص في
منتصف العمر لم تعلن تفاصيل عن اسمه ولم
تعلن اي تفاصيل جنائيه تتعلق بالدافع او
ما الى ذلك ما هو معروف حتى الان ان
السياره عبرت من الجهه الاخرى من الطريق
طريق وايت هول المقابل لمقر الحكومه
واصطدمت بالبوابه الضخمه السوداء التي
ترونها في الصوره هنا بوابه مقر الحكومه
من المعروف ان التوقيت كان الرابعه والثلث
مساء وهو توقيت خروج الموظفين العاملين في
الحكومه ومن المعروف ايضا ان رئيس الحكومه
كان في هذا في مقر الحكومه وايضا وزير
الخزانه
اثناء وقوع هذا الحادث
الاصطدام حسب الصور التي اذيت في الاعلام
المحلي لم يكن شديدا سير عبر ببطء ولم تكن
لم يبدو ان هناك نيه مبيتة لهجوم
وهناك شيء اخر ان الشرطه لم تطلق ولا حتى
رصاصه واحده المعلومات المتاحه ان الشرطه
التي تتعامل مع هذه القضيه حتى الان هي
شرطه مقر الحكومه شرطه
وليست شرطه
مكافحه الارهاب وبالتالي ليست هناك شبهه
ارهاب حتى الان حسب ما يقرا من البيانات
الصادره عن الشرطه الشرطه تقوم منذ قرابه
ساعتين باخذ ادله مختلفه من السياره وكما
ترى
مشاهد الجزيره الان اتت سياره تابعه
للشرطه بها ونش الاستعدادا لازاله هذه
السياره من امام مقر الحكومه واعاده
الطريق اعاده فتح الطريق بشكل كامل واعاده
الوضع الى طبيعته شكرا لك
اسد الله الصون وتحدثا من تن داونلود في
لندن شكرا